the Queen had said she wanted final
decisions within days and not weeks in a
statement came the confirmation a deal
had been done
she said I'm pleased that together we
found constructive and supportive way
forward for my grandson and his family
Harry
Megan and Archie will always be
much-loved members of my family I
recognize the challenges they've
experienced as a result of intense
scrutiny over the last two years and
support their wish for a more
independent life I want to thank them
for all their dedicated work across this
country the Commonwealth and beyond and
I'm particularly proud of how Megan has
so quickly become one of the family it
is my whole family's hope that today's
agreement allows them to start building
a happy and peaceful new life only ten
days ago the couple announced their
decision to step back in another
statement from Harry and Megan they said
they were grateful to the family and
outlined what this new working life
means they'll step back from royal
duties including official military
appointments they'll no longer receive
public funds they'll continue their
private patronage Asst but they will not
use their HRH titles they'll repay the
public funds used to refurbish Frogmore
cottage which will remain their UK
family home and when it comes to
security the palace said they don't
comment on security arrangements but
there are well-established independent
processes to determine the need for
publicly funded security this is an
abdication in a sense from the royal
family by Harry and he and his wife are
now free to a certain extent to go and
follow the dreams that they have to
pursue very good works it would seem in
the widest possible sense but no longer
part of the Royal business well they'll
no longer use their HRH titles they've
not been stripped of being Duke and
Duchess for Harry one of the hardest
parts of this new way of life is likely
to be the necessity to cut his ties with
his military patronage --is but while
they'll no longer formally represent the
Queen they will continue to uphold the
values of Her Majesty in everything they
do
Prince Harry will be doing he won't have
his
they're like Megan he won't have his
family there which I think he will
appreciate when they're not there rather
than you know when there is very close
to them Hollis sources said there was a
genuine desire to come up with this new
way of working and that everyone was
pleased that they've got to this point
this is such a dramatic shift that there
are inevitably still going to be details
that need to be worked out this has
caused the vision that the Queen has
wanted the disappointment and hurt to be
put to one site to allow Harry and Megan
to get on with the independent life that
they've craved